good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast today is Wednesday
hump day so hump someone if it's
consensual and we're just out here being
humpy we are welcome back to the show
I'm looking at today's show with a fresh
set of a new lens yesterday we did
something very scary and Pinton do sing
for us and a lot of the listeners but
also I think quite trailblazing of us
definitely uh actually not trailblazing
because it was a copy that idea it's a
copied idea but we did in a patron
episode of mean comments we went to our
podcast reviews and read the meanest
ones about us and responded to them from
ones that were you know critical but
constructive to ones that were just
plain mean right and we did an entire
episode really just coming for like
every single point addressing every
single point and talking about the
things that we would change given having
read all of this from some people who
seem like true fans the toasters and the
patreon community loved the episode I've
just been hearing rave reviews however
so many people are now saying like first
of all they like when we talk fast
they don't come to this show to become
so informed right and so what we took
from the show like the takeaways were
one we really need to slow down when we
talk because it makes it really
difficult for people to listen to that
we speak a lot about stuff like issues
that come up on tangents and we don't
really know we're not really well versed
in certain subjects and we just talk
with conviction about things that we
might not know are 100% certain right -
which people said like if you're coming
here for the news you're at the wrong
show right also they were upset that we
you know talk too much about ourselves
and not the Fast Five and then again
people said like this last time it's
just a way in which we get to talk about
ourselves know honestly that criticism
we might IRA buff it's called the Fast
Five for a reason I brutally rebuff that
if you're not interested in me or my
life and this podcast is not for you
yeah and then the complain which we
apologize for dnews annoying than
everyone said they loved our complaining
so so I think now taking both sides to
love and you know the criticism oh you
can do it do what you think is best
don't do what other people tell you to
do and that's what they said they love
us because we're unpadded unapologetic
we're who we are we're unfilter
and don't change further people but it's
also important I think to know what
people are critical of and be aware of
it a hundred percent so I will move
forward in a more meaningful way one in
which I speak a little bit slower and
I'm just a little bit more conscious of
speaking over my sister oh yes
definitely that was a win for me I kind
of don't mind being talked over
sometimes but sometimes I'm my sentence
is trailing off feel free to jump in
right right right
so head over to Peter I'm back home
slash the morning toast to listen to the
episode and we have three more premium
episodes coming at you this month we're
gonna film one later today the one we're
doing today is quit person and seeing as
how cam toeses this weekend we can't
wait to see our camp toasters when
you're going to do an episode centered
around our experience at fat camp a lot
of people might not know that as
children we went to fat camp for many
years and it was really some of the best
summers of my life and I just think a
lot of people to me it's just normal but
to some people it's like why yeah so we
had a lot of questions about that so if
you are patreon remember you want to
hear that it'll be coming up later today
or tomorrow yeah it's all good stuff
it's great stuff ahh I just I can't wait
for camp I already started packing I'm
trying to figure out what do I pack for
this again I'm I haven't what uh what
bag are you using I am using my way
luggage is now I have a cute little set
now that we're working with them on this
year's show so I have my carry-on and
then I have the bigger carry-on cuz I
need two suitcases those two suitcases
but nothing just two rollies but also
your bedding is not gonna go in it's
gonna go in there I can fit a comforter
in a rolling it's a blanket I'm gonna
fit it and also it's coming from like
it's being shipped so it's gonna be
condensed you know mine is all my
bedding came in an Amazon box and I left
it there I'm just gonna throw the box of
the car that's perfect so what what I'm
most excited about for camp toast is I'm
driving us there and I just I love a
good road trip especially with my
sister's like where should we stop along
the way for snacks oh I don't know but
at the camp coast road trip distance is
the perfect distance for road trip it's
it's like two hours yeah and when I
Drive like me it's two hours next week
I'm going up for my Colgate five-year
reunion which is just so crazy how are
you getting there um we're driving but
it's a five-hour road trip dad hasn't
sunk in yet
no but speaking of college I think I
might have to do this book a flight
sorry girls speaking of college we went
to Margo's college graduation yesterday
and it was pure torture and it really
made me think a lot about the hypocrisy
of our educational system you know
it's like all the kit was a two-hour
ceremony and the first 90 minutes were
such like [ __ ] self congratulating
like the professors and the Dean's on
stage it's like it's your job to be
there they were acting like they were
literally firefighters like your service
to these kids it's like you were so mean
to these kids these kids hate you oh
yeah and you got paid to be there where
some of these kids are putting
themselves in financial debt for the
rest of their lives just to get yelled
at by you it was just so a hypocritical
I was like this is such [ __ ] acting
like they're saving lives like for just
like these fake Research's grams yeah it
was so stupid and it's like we're here
to celebrate the kids and the kids were
literally the last five minutes they
like hurry to everyone off the stage and
it was just like so stupid yeah it was
really stupid it was it was painful
graduation ceremonies are just one of
the most painful life experiences for me
and I was looking around at the people
that were so excited to be there and
it's like I'm so happy for them but for
us it's like worst case scenario I don't
know I just have like little to no
respect for the higher education process
as a whole like from admissions to
graduation um so it was just hard for me
to sit there and my legs got like really
crappy and I'm so torturous in but like
my legs felt like I needed to stretch
them and I never feel that way cuz like
I have like one inch leg well the the
most interesting part was at the
graduation ceremony was at Radio City
Music Hall which just got me all excited
because snitchy
I'm all about you know accomplishing my
goals and then like feeling like they're
nothing and then getting to the next
thing like I haven't even done the
Beacon Theater yet but now I'm like I
gotta taste yeah so yes happy stage
graduated we were saying to her because
we met for dinner after where it's like
she doesn't even know like people are
like the real world sucks like being in
a Delta Delta is hard it's like none of
that it literally that [ __ ] pales in
comparison to like having a paper due
and knowing that Margo will never have
the feeling of like having homework
having a paper due having to study like
having a Pitt about a grade like that is
what being an adult is all about and
people don't talk about that enough
because there's no there's such
happiness and profound joy and and peace
in inner peace and knowing you will
never have to write another paper in the
post-grad life I do a lot of cameos for
people who are graduating from college
and that is really
it's the message the message like I'm
sure you're sad but just know like this
is the greatest thing that's ever
happened to you you know the world kind
of like puts out this message that like
once you graduate it's all fun until you
graduate but it's like neuro like
everything up until graduation sucks
yeah except for the summers right you
saw their summer reading where did that
narrative come from you know where it's
like it came from the higher education
system which is just trying to keep us
in gradually strangling people totally
wanting to take your fun so they make
you think that you need school and you
need continued school someone come today
after my sister's college graduation I
told my mom I'm running for office and
that my platform is gonna be for
enforced graduations to be an hour or
less well you know what I was thinking
thank you for bringing that up I was
thinking you know what if I want to run
for president I want to just get rid of
graduation ceremonies completely but for
some people it brings them truly so much
joy the people sitting there with their
camcorders and in some families like
this is the first generation and like
for those people I had chills like they
hung worse there are people who are
watching online and then I'm thinking
like who's watching this graduation
ceremony remotely it's like parents and
families who can't be here who are so
proud of that these kids I want to give
them my seat you know I should not be
there I agree there were like little
glimpses of like really true happiness
in the college graduation ceremony
that's a new era
ya think they were just like I wish I
spoke more about the kids like who
literally are like kids our daughters
and sons of immigrants who are like the
first people in their generation to
graduate from college like what a proud
moment no let's congratulate another
Dean and give her 30 minutes to talk
about a speech about that one time her
kid got a scrape on her leg like it's so
stupid yeah it's so I mean I guess we
heard from one student I guess
technically graduations are optional for
everyone yeah but no it's like you want
to have it's nice to like commemorate
the moment like you've worked hard for
four years you want to have a ceremony
and that's like the premise behind why
graduations were started but they've
gotten so ahead of themselves like
literally of all the speakers there was
one kid who spoke yeah Val Victoria
Vallot right there should be like you
know obviously though there should be a
Dean you know guiding us through the
ceremony but like I want to hear from
the students I want to hear from miss or
mr. congeniality of the class like you
know give me some personality that's
celebrate the students not the school
like they gave out awards to kids and
the person who spoke the whole time was
a Dean and he liked littering the kids
didn't even get to speak they got their
award he got pushed off the stage it was
so crazy it was literally like the most
self congratulatory thank you well-liked
righteous self righteous it was such
[ __ ] I was really like getting so
mad while I was sitting there no I think
it's we have to celebrate the students
in the class not the school we
celebrated the school the UCAV boatloads
of tuition money right a bit loan debt
like you've been celebrated sufficiently
money taken care of let's hear from the
kids had they turnout wobbles jury's
still out on Snitch since she's just
graduated without a job and we're just
looking forward to watching her you know
spread her wings and fly into the world
yes I'm so happy for the snitch um she's
the type of person who didn't handle
like school pressure well so I'm really
happy she she won't be having that fur
for the rest of her life that her
Instagram stories are no longer like her
studying in library like ya know promise
the contents out to be like even more
premium yeah but other than that it was
a great day and we're here again just to
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast okay
are you ready to get into it
are you ready yeah my foot fell asleep
so just like a minute don't worry the
stories aren't as heavy as they've been
so I hope you can stay informed we're
gonna be recapping Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills at the end of the episode
yes okay first up inside Kylie Jenner's
Kylie skin launch party with James
Charles and Caitlyn Jenner Kylie Jenner
wasn't going to let her Kylie skin skin
launch pass without an epic party the
beauty mogul celebrated the release of
the first products from her new skincare
line officially available on Wednesday
at 9:00 a.m. Pacific time
okay that's 12 noon Eastern Time on
Tuesday night with an over-the-top all
pink party that included a roller
skating rink lots of junk food and
everyone from James Charles to Caitlyn
Jenner Kim Khloe and Kourtney were all
in attendance as was Chris Cory gamble
but Kendall was halfway around the world
for a cam Film Festival tons of beauty
influencers showed their support
including James Charles who recently
ended a feud with his mentor taki
Westbrook also present were Nikita
dragon and Gabriel's Mora
so we know whose side Kylie has taken
yes as shiri followed James Charles so
that's the thing it's like the only
thing not adding up here
is why she unfollowed him and if she
followed him back and that was the thing
the only piece of James Charles a story
that I didn't fully like by was when he
was talking about the Dolan twins and
how like he's spoken to them whatever
but it's like if he they're really your
friend you're they're one of the only
few people you're talking to you during
this huge scandal like and they
unfollowed you want to Instagram that's
just weird
it is weird and like Nick heated drug
gun did not yeah I just want to say I
know this wasn't working straight and I
hate when people like talk up real drama
to just be our yard stunt however this
is a party that would have happened say
this James Charles Tati Westbrook thing
hadn't happened in the Kylie skin party
right up it would not be a headline
celebrates with James Charles yeah Tati
Westbrook's name would not be mentioned
in the article no this really this whole
scandal has Gabriel Zamora I've never
heard of him well you want to know why I
think Kylie I mean Kylie took this side
because one her and James like have a
history but also I think Kylie [ __ ]
hates Jeffrey star because he's always
so mean about her products i things now
recently been taken off of her press
list like he used to get her her
products early on and review them and
only only say negative things about like
the inconsistencies of the formula and
how the price point it's too high and I
can't just like be a celebrity and put
your name on something so she has since
stopped sending him product and I think
it was just easy for her to take James
aside here oh definitely but I'm just
saying like this whole scandal and drama
has made James Charles an even bigger
star Gabriel Zamora I've said his name
four times on the show now yeah and it's
net it's a fun name to say well a
personal update in this entire thing was
that I had ordered some James Charles
merch maybe a week before the scandal
even happen as everyone knows if they've
been listening to the toasts like I have
just been becoming a James Charles fan
like over the past few months and
decided to get some merch one because I
want to support but also it's his
sisters on it so it has nothing to do
with James Charles like I love my
sisters and now I have it on my phone
case I don't see you so literally the
day that the drama went out I decided to
turn on James Charles I got an email
that it had shipped and I was feeling so
perplexed and then it arrived at the
same day where I was like kind of
turning back for James Charles so I've
decided to wear it and wear it proudly
I'm happy I think that's that's your
choice you're not I'm happy for you
know that I am
even if maybe if I don't sing in like an
annoying belty way more of like a
soothing calming way people will think
it's like ASMR maybe because Wednesday
is here once we did a little cover of
rainbow by Kacey Musgraves in a really
like high-pitched sweet way and people
really enjoyed it
well Jackie and I were saying yesterday
on the patreon episode was that we don't
really sing anymore but the only time we
sing on the show is when one of us says
I'm kind of what I'm happy for you
because there's no way you can say those
words and not just go in to know that I
am I'll stop there okay are you gonna
get stuff so people are all up in arms
which was a similar scam but what
happened on the toast because when I
guess when it's getting uh potential was
here she was talking about st. Ives and
the toasters went off saying that they
use walnut no she said that they use
plastic feeds and that because I was
just telling her I bought it as my
exfoliate her and she said don't use it
these classic beads then the toaster
found out that they have it was a whole
scandal they have changed to natural
exfoliating beads so it actually is okay
to use now there was a recall on
everything but so we just cleared that
right up but so Kylie's using walnut
she's using natural so what I said I met
there Magnus apparently it's a little
too rough on the skin no I'm totally
buying one cuz I just love to support
and to like I've been pretty pleased
with Kylie cosmetics as far as so why
not yeah I mean it'll be good it'll be
no cope re you know aluminum free
coconut geo daram but not everything can
be it's good it's go par yet natural do
not everything can be as good as cope re
and you know what that's just our cross
to bear so tell them Mike hope re is so
incredible because Co parries coconut
children is a cleaner alternative to a
traditional deodorant it's aluminum free
vegan and doesn't contain silicone
sulfates parabens GMOs or baking soda
instead the deodorant keeps you fresh
with plant-based actives like sage oil
and coconut oil it's great if you have
sensitive skin if you're looking for a
deodorant with the scent that's not
overpowering or if you're like me and
you literally can't get your pits to
stop smelling from anything from a
drugstore right so go to cope re
beauty.com slash toast to save five
dollars off your first deodorant when
you subscribe that's Kapaa recom
oh sorry that's cope re beauty.com Kop
AR i beauty.com slash toast cope re
beauty.com slash toast you never have to
worry about running out of giotto right
because claipari offers a subscription
you get it automatically shipped you
often as you choose for free so free
yeah so let's go party beauty.com
slash toast every time we do a coke are
you read like a camera guess it's wings
totally it's me such great joy it's one
of my favorite beauty brands and I'm so
grateful to work with that modern
honored okay there was an interesting
weight dare I say blessed there was an
interesting factoid in this article that
I just didn't want to skirt the James
Charles one the Carl Erskine article
Caitlyn Jenner was there with girlfriend
Sophia Hutchins however the skin care
launch could be a bit of a sore subject
for the former Olympian her own line was
nixed by the United States Patent and
Trademark Office because her application
for Jenner skincare was too similar to
the already protected Kylie skin oh my
god thanks here one Caitlyn Jenner one
sort of skincare line and to Kylie has
the trademark you know what now that I
think about it it's like hmm who would
come up with a better formula a 21 year
old with perfect skin and a team of
people to take care of her or someone
who's lived quite a life this is some
when we talked about the Kylie skin
launched last week with cinch this is
what I said like as much as I love Kylie
and I'll probably wind up buying these
products it's hard for me to take
skincare advice from a 21 year old who
essentially has perfect skin right no
like it's not hard to maintain but it's
good and when you're young and beautiful
right you don't know the struggles of
crow's feet right so I'm I'm quicker to
go check out Ramona's ageless by Ramona
Singer like truly yeah that's true it's
the proof is in the pudding yeah
the proof is really in the pudding but I
mean I think a bench I mean firstly a
foaming face wash I could definitely try
out Kylie I also think like Caitlyn
Jenner like really needs to stay in her
Lane like we have k'kaw Beauty we have
Kylie cosmetics we have Kylie skin we
have so much here that I just don't
think we need a Caitlyn Jenner skincare
moment I would much rather see like a
caitlyn jenner like athleisure line you
know like let's step out of the beauty
like we've got a cover know like
everyone's out of control then you see
that kendall is trademarking her name in
the beauty world to shut up like Kendall
and Kendall's beauty or something
Kendall's it's the same exact thing
Kendall wears no make I'm like when she
did that Dior Vogue makeup bathroom
thing she was wearing like literally
chapstick and concealer no and then also
would she not be able to be
face of other beauty brands right I
don't think in any way that this is a
good idea hey but you know what is a
good idea that I literally just thought
up even though whatever like Kylie's the
face of Kylie cosmetics like maybe
Kendall should be
she's model but I'm and they have the
budget um it's a good idea except like I
for those of us who like love Kylie
because it's kind of a worse I wouldn't
I wouldn't want it no custody nice if
you see bang estee lauder
honestly maybe do Chen but I let her
know maybe can touch me the face of
k'kaw beauty but like you buy it like
she's the mrs. West collection you buy
because it's like what's your wedding
I'm just trying to find some work for
Kendall yeah she's okay she's in Caston
can't she's busy she really is okay okay
ready for our next story which you know
what I'm looking to you as the expert on
I know you've been sort of like out of
touch but you are our resident Shahs of
Sunset expert oh I know about it and
there's major going on major drama going
on between dresses and out of touch why
would you say that because you've been
on vacation okay no I've been very
informed oh but I didn't mean it I
didn't know if like something happened
where I'm like now considered out of
touch I'm sorry because all this went
down while you were on vacation and some
of my friends were texting me like
what's the drama like what's going on
and I just seen an Instagram post I was
like honestly I don't know I had to ask
Claudia but you were on a flight that's
why I consider out of touch fair sorry
for that is the clarification uh what's
going on well be the headline give
people the facts Sarah and Mercedes MJ
Javeed a complete timeline of the shots
of sunset stars viewed the Shahs of
Sunset stars are currently embroiled in
a heated feud which came to a head
just yesterday after Reza obtained a
restraining order against MJ's husband
and fellow cast mate Tommy while the
stars have yet to weigh in on the latest
development in the drama resident MJ's
friendship appears to have hit I'm sorry
a rough patch sometime throughout her
pregnancy before giving birth to her son
shams Francis fight a source told a news
that Javeed was heartbroken by her
friends especially after being admitted
into the ICU quote MJ is confused and
heartbroken that her friends haven't
congratulated her on chances birth which
were asked her about bless you thinking
or asked her about her health you're not
allowed to sneeze no that was another
complaint I just held it in really tight
I'm sorry we're not allowed to sneeze in
and we can't breathe either I mean let
me tell you this is what I do as far as
I know they just restarted filming I
think that they waited for MJ to like be
giving birth like start the season
because she
a bunch of complications and they wanted
her involved now it is my understanding
that a storyline was started by MJ that
you know the group wasn't really there
for her cuz she had a really tough
pregnancy and then once once she gave
birth she's in the ICU she lost a lot of
blood like it was really scary she was
there for like a whole day just she was
in labor for like two days and a
storyline was started and people were
saying to the press like MJ's really
upset none of her friends were there for
her and Reza took that really personally
because Reza's her best friend and he
was according to him totally there for
her and so he first posted screenshots
of his text message conversations with
Tommy on his Instagram basically proving
because they said he never visited in
the hospital and he was asking to visit
MJ's texting from Tommy's phone being
like no I don't really want to see
anyone but he kept checking in for
updates like he was just proving that he
was there being a friend tried to come
see her but even though she didn't want
to be seen he was keeping up finding out
how she was doing like every day so when
the story line is now becomes that Reza
wasn't there for her he's incensed and
post this photo but the photo did have a
bunch of her medical information so
people were like you really can't be
sharing her medical information so he
took it down so he looks guilty when he
does that
but then literally the next day there's
he they have a nest and their front yard
camera found Tommy and Jays husband come
to the front yard and [ __ ] like take
all their furniture throw bases at the
window like so not to vandalize their
entire front yard and their house and
they posted the video on their Instagram
they now have a restraining order
against Tommy like it's getting really
bad which is like so crazy because and
now they're like posting all of us on
Instagram being so public like everyone
like GG and Mike is like has taken
Reza's side so it looks like it's gonna
be everyone against MJ would you say
because this is like a good time in MJ
stuff and like everyone was there for
her when her dad died they should be
there like celebrate with her man it
looks like it's not going so well whose
side are you on because I know you
really love both of them yeah well I am
an MJ Stan but I'm an MJ Stan in the
sense that like I you know you just like
love someone unapologetically like I do
think Reza was definitely there for
Reza's obsessive like this this kid is
residency in the text messages he was
ready to come anytime she was able to
see him so I mean I just think I take MJ
side because I love her but I do think
she might have been you know I mean and
I can't condone violence I
in someone's house Tommy's out of
control I don't care what happened you
don't go to someone's house and like
start throwing furniture at the window I
love MJ so I just I understand her a
little bit but Reza Reza has been a lot
of things over his time but he's always
been a good friend and he's always like
pretty logical and he's obsessed with MJ
like I can't even think for one second
that he wouldn't want to be there every
second up her but when she's pregnant
this feels like to me like a
miscommunication this is the type one
and the grameen me who really wants to
see both sides and like I don't think
either of them did anything wrong it's
just like the way that they heard
information yeah
just wasn't right which sucks positive
outcome but then the way that how far it
came like it doesn't matter what the
miscommunication was thinking whatever
be friends with Tommy after he
vandalized their house I mean you never
know like Kris and Dodi slept with Jax
Taylor and anything can happen what's
true that's just how I think yeah
especially on reality show that's true
and when it's like they're your cast
member their coworker
it behooves you to get along at a
certain point but like Golnesa I feel
like it's just like love being living
for this because she's always been like
MJ's a bad person I'm just a bad person
and Reza it has impacted her
relationship with Reza because Brad's
always takes MJ's side as does the
audience so actually I think this will
be a great season I just I mean I love
shots of sunset I'll say it once I'll
say it again it's truly the most
underrated show and underappreciated
show on Bravo and this is so crazy crazy
speaking of more crazy reality TV drama
crystals to pay 2.5 million dollar fine
and not a fine in a fatal car crash
settlement so yesterday crystals
sentencing was live-streaming and
crystals is praying the price for his
part in the fatal car crash that killed
a 66 year old man Kenneth Moser never
forget according to a settlement and
release a group Eamonn obtained by we
are Iowa calm Chris and his parents Gary
and Linda souls are required to pay 2.5
million dollars to the family of the
victim Kenneth Mosier as part of a
wrongful death lawsuit the two parties
entered the agreement in January 2019
however it was only recently approved on
Tuesday May 21st
first the reality star was due to be
sentenced for leaving the scene of the
accident but the sending scene was
delayed so that the court can remove the
victim impact statements from the
pre-sentencing report according to the
Des Moines Register the
could be rescheduled as early as August
for his crime he faces up to two years
in prison okay this story is so sad all
around it showed that inducing its soap
it inducing and I recently saw on the
e-news Instagram like a quote from
Rebecca Gayheart who apparently in the
early 2000s accidentally killed like a
young boy in a car accident and magog
and I guess she just recently gave an
interview about it where she said like
for a year after that like she was just
trying to find ways to kill herself like
she did not want to live until like
right now this story is a horrible for
everyone involved and from what we know
of the story like this was a pure
accident his biggest crime was leaving
the scene he was drinking like it was
just bad but I really feel for him right
to drinking he I think he had had some
beers like I don't know his level of
drunk but he left the crime scene
because like if he was there and they
took his butt out how it would have been
like drinking and driving so now they
can't show that it's not an accident no
but like now they can't prove that he
was drunk because he wasn't there to get
his blood alcohol level taken there was
like a pack of beer in the front I don't
know I don't know right no I mean either
it's an accident or it's a drunk driving
and drug driving I don't feel bad for
crystals um
I don't think he was like I think it was
both you know it was there aren't like
lights on the streets at night this guy
was in a tractor trip like a trailer I
believe um and I think it was just
really unfortunate yeah but it could
have been like easier to see the tractor
like if you weren't drunk if you hadn't
been drinking right I don't know how
drunk he was and nobody will ever know
no we won't but like him she him running
away doesn't bode well for what his
blood-alcohol content would have been
right and if it was above then this is
not an accident he showed a show but
apparently called 9-1-1 before anyone
iraq both and fled before they arrived
at least he called 911 you know cuz i
know you're watching dead to me now my
god this was making me think of that
okay I better I have to say I loved the
show up too and I'm not taking episode 9
okay try not to get too many spoilers so
like well you're right it's just like I
didn't know what type of show it was
gonna be and I still don't really know
I'm just like really Linda Cardellini is
like scaring me so much she's being like
such a good actress I like she's
freaking me out like I was watching it
alone in bed at night and I had to turn
I changed the channel cuz I was afraid
yeah but it's like not a scary show but
then it it's Christina Applegate is such
a good actress because her whole her
characters like in group
grief mode the entire season and she's
such a good crier yeah also I just love
James Martin I think anytime he gets on
television he will never not be corny
Collins but anytime we gets on
television I just like love it I love
him so much it's a great show um there
are some common themes here I don't want
to give too much away but if they had
called 911 right maybe something would
have happened maybe something could have
been changed because like he wasn't
found till the next morning
right giving him ample time who knows
like what he actually got yeah no I mean
Hey so I good on crystals but like I'm
not here like congratulate feeling bad
for crystals I'm pretty sure he was
drunk I
yeah like we're sympathetic to him
because he's like a cutie from Iowa and
like we loved him on the background like
you wanted to go out on that season but
like sorry a chunk John Force is your
juror yeah agreed
I just had it was a weird time having
just read Rebecca Gayheart to interview
where like the year after was Rebecca
Gayheart drunk I don't think so I don't
and we don't know how drunk he was Chuck
we okay what if it was just two three
beers still okay so I'm a nerd like any
time and has a drink or like the fact
that people smoke pot and drive is so
crazy to me so like I'm a nerd like if
anyone I know has a drink like I
literally will shove them in a car like
I will not let them drive even if it's
like a sip of wine or if I've had a sip
of wine and I'm like the only person who
could drink I'm like drive I'm like
sorry I'm not coming like I'm a nerd
like that and I think that should be
adopted everywhere so a few beers and a
car no that's bad way of thinking okay
fine fine call me a square call me
old-fashioned I don't think people
should drink a drive so do you think the
blood-alcohol level should be zero point
zero yes totally
for the law yeah if you have a drink
don't drive okay with in okay when it
was point eight when people have needed
cars to get from point A to point B I
understand in the age of uber it should
be like point four that's fair that's
fair yeah okay that's what I'm running
for president four that's my platform
cool thanks next up new study finds CBD
could curb heroin addiction non
psychoactive chemical component of
cannabis reduced cravings anxiety among
heroin
users cannabidiol or CBD the non
psychoactive chemical compound found in
cannabis could be used to fight heroin
addiction according to a new study
published by the American Journal of
Psychiatry the new study focused
specifically focused on whether CBD
could curve craving and anxiety among
heroin users not only did the study find
that CBD immediately helped reduce
cravings among heroin users it also
noted the effects seem to last seven
days after the subjects word was so dose
of CBD speaking with CNN Yasmine heard
the lead researcher on the study said
the intense craving is what drives the
drug use
if we can have the medications that
dampen that craving that can greatly
reduce the chance of relapse in overdose
risk wait that's so crazy I mean I feel
personally connected to heroin ever
since I saw this episode of dr. Phil
about the three sisters who can stop
doing heroin and like it really shook me
to my core and I just like I'm so like
not like obsessed like I got away but
just like intrigued it's my hair away
cuz like everyone's doing heroin now
like it's like the number one most
popular drug like more so than pot in
New Jersey cuz it's so cheap yeah so and
we're in the know and we're we're we're
the number one podcast it's also the
world it's also the worst drug like have
you ever seen someone on heroin I think
I have once
like that's not confirmed no but like a
person on the street like you become
unconscious and like you know what you
can't even walk oh yeah you're like a
sleep as I think also in Breaking Bad
with Krysten Ritter
I don't watch Kristen Riggs like a
heroin girl um yeah so I think this is
great
I've been newly into CBD and well I
don't need it to carry my heroin issues
more like my tendinitis I am here for
just more positive effects he's been use
CBD for his carpal tunnel so we just got
home and I never even thought to use it
on him and I should have taken it to
Israel because he's been sleeping in a
wouldn't got like a cast which helped
but I thought I've been using the CBD on
my left thumb I have tendinitis and it
comes every now and then and I got a CBD
cream and it totally helps so last night
I put it on Ben's wrist and he like he
like it's just so annoying like
something could work and make him feel
so much better because it doesn't to
give me the credit like for fixing his
problem he's like it kind of feels
better
you know yes annoying
okay this and final story seeking of
just
speaking of speaking okay that's my
Segway New York might make it illegal to
text while walking I want to get your
thoughts on this ooh
crossing the street here in New York can
be challenging at any time and you might
be even less likely to notice that
honking cab I mean you'll notice you
because you hear it or zooming
bicyclists if you're looking at your
phone now it could become illegal to do
so a bill in the New York State Senate
seeks to ban pedestrians from using
portable electronic devices while
crossing the road fines would range from
$25 to 250 dollars the statewide ban
would include texting checking emails
and browsing the internet with
exceptions for emergencies well this is
so fascinating because I had an
experience last night when I was walking
home from dinner where I walked half a
block like I didn't cross any streets I
just walked half a block and I was
texting and I realized I'm like I
thought to myself I'm like I just cross
the street like I couldn't remember I
was like in Hazen I'm like damn I need
to be more careful and I put my phone
away so like I understand the like
desire to make it illegal but like this
literally sounds like a robot state
where like everything we do is
controlled by the government and like if
the government can control what I do
with my hands like that's crazy yeah it
seems a little invasive but I actually
don't think it's the worst idea um and
it says if it's just fines like starting
at $25 like that'll just encourage
people to not do it and it really is so
unsafe especially because in New York
the way that traffic patterns aren't
even if you have the light you think
like even if I text who cares but other
lanes can still turn and you you should
be aware I think it'll incur I mean I
don't know how many first of all we'll
see if it passes yeah and once it passes
I don't know you know this is how the
government will be making its money but
it will definitely encourage people to
not be on their phones while they yes I
mean I'm very reticent to give the
government more power to control like my
personal life so while I said I
understand the need for it I'm not here
for it because like this literally
sounds like an episode of black where
like right that's like so it is it can
make the argument that it's not so
dissimilar to not being able to be on
your phone while you're driving no but
when you're driving on your phone you're
a danger to others yeah that's why it's
legal but you texting on your phone
while walking on the street you're just
gonna putting yourself in danger I mean
you're putting yourself you're danger to
yourself but then say someone hits you
and then you we're in their lives okay
emotionally yeah but like technically
they're fine and what they have what
your family sues them and like then all
of a sudden they're out yeah but if you
get like that litigious like you could
say that about everything that you
shouldn't be able to walk your dog on
the street because then we could eat
your dog and your dog you can't control
the dogs and then the dog it's about the
kind of serves that I'm just saying it's
a chain reaction no it is but like if
you think that way like you can say that
about everything angry I don't know like
it's like this is just like so extreme
I'm not like you know someone who's like
hit they're like the Sabo something like
law every time something is a problem in
society but if this past you know I
wouldn't take up in arms and go pro to
Sun City Hall do you remember when
Bloomberg was trying to cut down the
size of our sodas and he didn't remember
when he took salt off the tables right
so it's like to me it's like I
understand like you have a good
intentions like should I be drinking a
big gulp this big at 7:00 in the morning
no is it your business Bloomberg no is
it your choice yes so it's like that's
something where I'm only harming myself
so like the government needs to get out
of my dick that's like cigarettes it's
like okay you know what if people want
to smoke cigarettes like that's their
prerogative like why so nosey the
government like it's a [ __ ] Adam I don't
smoke cigarettes and I think it's gross
that other people do but like that's
their [ __ ] prerogative you want to
give yourself cancer run go have a good
time
here yeah I hear ya okay so that's our
fifth and final story really a nice
range a lot of the legal news a lot of
drugs news lots of drug news now we have
to recap Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills and I'm gonna I'm gonna segue us
in with a a little bit of a sixth story
getting crazy because Lisa Vanderpump is
coming under fire because she's had made
a anti-trans comment about Erika Jayne
last night on the show if you watch the
show I'm sure the minute you saw it you
were like googling what is tucking oh no
the minute I saw it I was like oh this
[ __ ] is done you know how I knew what
tucking is how amazed Ventura
very cool remember very close anyways so
she made up one of her unnecessary jabs
when it's like no one no one no one Lisa
Vanderpump talking [ __ ] about Erika
Jayne who literally doesn't say anything
about like Lenore it positive or
negative
doesn't speak your name I mean so yeah
like why so when she was getting her
life
to test they asked her questions about
droids face because John Sesa Blizzard
John 3:16 all of the John's are such
[ __ ] [ __ ] starters they leaked the
story to Raider online come at me get
dawn in the chair
yes the [ __ ] chair he was being so
thirsty and losery like I wanted to
select him across the face so many
thoughts anyways they asked the question
about her each days and then in her side
commentary unprompted she said Lisa
Vanderpump just don't ask me if Erica's
tucking or something like that because
there are some things I can't lie about
and then she chuckled off so regardless
of who you are this is a transphobic
comment like it's mean and it's so catty
do I think Lisa is transphobic no she
has been very vocal as an ally of the
LGBTQ community but she should know
better because she has been an ally and
that doesn't give you like a free pass
just to be an ally I mean just to say
whatever you want so she needs to but
people like saying she's transphobic
it's not but it's like the perfect
example of like what's wrong with Lisa
Vanderpump do you know yeah like she
thinks she can say whatever she won't
know it's like wasn't it was a
transforming comment I don't think she's
transphobic woman she's like Erika
phobic she yes she's human folk okay you
know who I want to hear from Billy Lee
true like Billy Lee was out here
accusing all the venom from pearls kids
of being transphobic for not including
her on a flyer which is the biggest
reach it's this it's a reach it's it's
the land that Brown holds now yeah
and Lisa let her like have that
storyline uh let her have that storyline
but she shut it down at the reunion so
I'm just saying I want to hear from
Billy Lee
agreed I wonder if Billy Lee tweeted
anything because people were going off
on Twitter like LVP I understood by
people were upset by the comment I I do
agree with you that I don't think she's
transphobic um but it was just in so
many ways such an unnecessary
rude and offensive comment and no one
asked like literally Erica's name wasn't
even brought up Erica's not even a part
of this
Erica's probably the one person who is
most removed from the LVPD gate from
puppy gate overall yeah she didn't tweet
anything Billy Lee I just checked so
let's talk about the episode we start
with the lie-detector test and I just
there's so many logistics is the
lie-detector test because first when I
watched this man I was like he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about the
the LVP the johnson john blizzards John
3:16 of it all yeah like he is here for
the lies and everything was like
certified liar calm yeah and I was like
he might have done it I was like you
know what like he seems legit like yeah
he's gonna give you the straight facts
then I come to find out he's been on
every mediocre reality show marriage
boot camp Dre Jay Ray J then I saw a
tweet and I almost so want to bring it
up because like people on Twitter are so
factually inaccurate it came from like a
random account I don't even know if it
had a profile picture but that basically
this guy is not certified like he I
don't want to slander this guy's name
based on a rogue tweet that I saw but
that would go to say that like he has
absolutely no qualification well I mean
lie detector tests are like semi
reliable they're not admissible in court
so it's like even if it was the most
legit lie detector test ever it's still
not really considered foolproof and
considering this guy is like a reality
star fiend I don't give it the the great
oz yeah also I don't know how I detector
tests work I hope I never have to take
one but you coming in with your
questions yeah that Lisa I mean she
could probably if it's not a surprise
question like she'll know how to answer
them also some of the cutting the
answers to a test some of the questions
were like so we weren't worried whether
or not you were lying it's like do you
think your relationship with this lady's
are over yes shocking not a lie like
these are like um like these are all
opinion questions they're factual
questions also they didn't ask the
question what I needed which is like did
anyone in your camp leak this story do
you have knowledge of anyone leaking
this story would you the first time you
read the story when was it yeah blah
blah blah anyways the whole thing is so
stupid and then I thought what was even
reaching her was was the way they
introduced it to the ladies Kyle's
daughters friends construction workers
so stretchy what yeah that's a good call
like I don't know if that but like Lisa
is so divided from them how else would
she have found out like the verdict like
someone told her right but I kept her do
senator he came up with a stupid story
but like if you think about it Lisa is
so far removed from the group she
literally doesn't have a relationship
with one of the ladies that literally
how actually they could have been like
John says uh told Teddy's brother like
where they saw an Instagram story yeah
or
like I'm sorry all the construction
workers heading over to certified liar
net sauces notice the same days Lisa
Vanderpump like I'm just not buying you
know but that actually was really funny
what also was hysterical was Mauricio
Umansky being hi hysterical it's Jerry
why you look so fun I'm dying to go okay
Hawaii looked so fun but like I was
having so many thoughts about Camille
Grammer and they were dark and negative
because she's pissing me off so much
first of all like she's acting like
these ladies are her best friends and
they're not like I would say of all them
she's closest with Kyle and I say that
with this stretch i keeping kyle was
shocked to be asked to be a bridesmaid
but Camille is so desperate to get to go
back on the show that she would invite
someone she literally hate steady to her
wedding just so she could get time and
she spent the entire wedding weekend
with these six ladies so she's not
friends with like she and her mom was
their mom's living on like she's mad
more time with Kyle that she did with
her mom yeah Camille is so thirsty like
and so obvious in her thirst like I'm
thirsty too but at least I'm subtle
about it you know yeah she was pissing
me off
like to no end I just I love a trip for
the ladies I litter and I like when
these ladies get along like people think
it's boring but I found it interesting I
found it interesting - I literally
gasped when I saw Lisa Rinna ready for
the wedding she looked incredible
incredible and then I was like oh no
door eats wearing that color no jury
looked so incredible on this trip I was
just like looking at her and like even
her she doesn't we know she doesn't work
out because she said that before like
but like her back muscles yeah I was so
shook by her and like she wore her hair
I think she was I don't think they
brought glam glam she wore her hair and
like a slicked back button that like I
wear when I'm getting a massage and like
she wore it at Camille's wedding well
when she's getting ready so beautiful
when she was getting ready for Camille's
wedding she was trying on three pairs of
sunglasses and she went with the third
pair wouldn't even wear the worst which
made worse by worst yeah I agree that
was like the one her side was like
didn't get to that detail yeah it was a
pretty wedding it was it made me like
want to have a destination wedding in
Hawaii yeah they all looked like they
had a good time like it can be torture
to go to that destination wedding but if
everyone like just really like puts you
know just goes all-in with Teddy then
it's that it's good did you see this
below deck yeah I want to read so KH s
teen who was the chief stew on below
deck regular I want to say she's always
like tweeting she watches housewives
she's always tweeting stuff and people
care cuz she was on a Bravo show she's
just
like being mean and that's what she's
like Twitter care yeah 1111 make-a-wish
a wonderful weekend filled with love and
toasty vibes great one and world peace
so Cape chest ain't tweeted about the
moment where Teddy's in the pool crying
with Edwin that she has guilt about
working more but she really wants to
work more and she doesn't want to sell
have her company but she has this mom
guilt so she tweeted I'm still not
really sure what an accountability coach
does but I'm pretty certain it doesn't
require more time away from one's
children than any other job the millions
of working mothers have which like I
guess it's like a fair point but it's
like she wasn't saying her job is more
no I'm consuming then she wasn't
comparing herself you're comparing she
was just saying like I want to work I'm
not that I have to work but I want to
work my business is growing and I don't
feel like I should have to like give
that up because my kids cry every time I
leave yeah no it was definitely another
ricci vibe but then she responded Teddy
Mellencamp said and I'm sure the
millions of working moms struggled with
mom guilt at some point never said my
job in time was more important or
different but if judging my feelings as
a mother makes you happy go off I guess
which was a great response yes exactly
that I just had like she wasn't
comparing why are you convinced not
saying I'm the hardest swimming working
woman in the world make a chest day and
like totally had to swallow her pride
and was like I accept accountability for
all my Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
tweets past present and future and I'm
about to eat a pint of pistachio gelato
I like trying to make a joke is like you
got called out for being a veg like I'm
good I don't know what made me sad that
jury didn't eat the pasta I know that
pasta looks so petty ate it I know and
then I then I saw her back and it was
like okay I guess you can't eat pasta
but like that's a once in a lifetime
kind of pasta I have to tell you
something like this episode really like
transforms me into like I've always been
a fan of Kyle but like I think I'm like
Kyle's number one fan she's a great
housewife she is when they were talking
about the life insurance health in Ben
was watching with me at the time he was
like we would literally be in last place
like we would get the worst life
insurance and it's so true I just like I
loved Kyle's marriage I loved Kyle's
relationships with the ladies Kyle being
so funny about being a bridesmaid like
what am I supposed to do like I'm a 50
year old bride say like that was so
funny like I just really like finding
myself being shaping into a kayo-san
yeah I think that works for you yeah
she's like I'd like her she's great
style she has great everything she buys
is like fancy from interrex and like
they don't give me a coat on honey and
it's torture oh right like every time
there's a
Beverly Hills episode her injury like I
really look for what they wear and they
do share it sometimes on Instagram it's
just like a little out of my budget but
I'm getting there no one with honey
you'll be there yeah because saving
money is something we can all agree on
the reality is if you're not shopping
around you're probably not saving money
so what if there was a way for somebody
to do the shopping around for you well
that's exactly what honey does honey is
a free tool that you download on your
computer's browser while you shop online
honey scans the entire internet for
coupon codes promo codes discounts and
then it automatically applies the coupon
with the biggest savings to your cart at
checkout it's literally like magic I
found out about it from the toasters in
the toasters group I've been using it
for like two years and it has changed my
life and what's great a said it reminds
you before you check out because I'll
forget but a little thing will pop up
it's like you want to scan I'm like sure
honey do your thing
give me code tulip on revolve literally
every time I shop it's a buckin best
there's no reason not to use honey it's
free to use and easy to installing on
your computer in just two clicks don't
take it from us take it from our
listeners get honey for free at join
honey calm / toast that's join honey
dot-com / toast the smart shopping
assistant that saves you time and money
I love honey and I love that we found
out about it through the toasters at
first and then we go to word the helping
you join honey for free so I don't over
there um I do agree though I love this I
was just like loving der Ichi is
becoming and Erica wasn't on this
episode at all because she's always my
favorite housewife but der Reed is
becoming one of my favorite housewives
which is so very crazy can I talk the
most smack well she came out she came on
strong and she she came on in a way you
don't want to come on like as the friend
of the villain as the friend of the
villain but also like then coming for
someone who is a fan favorite Erica yeah
so like in when you I don't know what
the right way to come in to a housewife
role is especially when there's such
established relationships but don't come
for the fan favorite cuz that's a big
mistake I'll tell you the right way to
come in Denise Richards even though the
first few episodes I was hard on her
because I don't care about Charlie Sheen
but now I do because he brought a hooker
to thanks kid oh my god that was so
interesting and she's like said oh boy
that is was so many she was filming a
[ __ ] Christmas movie no mark
she is my housewife yes I love her I
feel so badly that I like was not
patient with her yeah you know no one's
gonna make a splash the first episode
yeah and
she's bringing so much to the show next
week she like goes to bat for Lisa Rinna
again scam returns and like that is the
kind of housewife fighting I need
because she's she has no stake like she
just doesn't owe anyone anything nobody
brought her on the show so she really
like she sings on tactics objectively
and just says how she feels like even in
the beginning she was a little reticent
she like jump on the I hit Lisa
Vanderpump ship she gave her a chance
like how a normal human being would do
who has no idea who Lisa Vanderpump is
yeah so I'm loving her addition to the
show me too I'll be really interested to
see her at the Reunion cuz like I don't
really feel like she's a housewife yet
like she doesn't like Instagram and
tweet like I'm out house might be stuff
she's still just like a celebrity Juneau
Deanne so once she's like once you get
into reunion and you get like down and
the dirt like there's no denying your
Housewives I just can't believe that the
New York women have already film their
reunion I know and the Beverly Hills
women haven't I know we're waiting for
the Lisa of it all but New York started
so much later than negative yeah Beverly
Hills started in the middle of February
and New York I feel like just started
yeah New York you feel like just started
because like every episode has been
terrible but ya know Beverly Hills
definitely started before and it's weird
but maybe it's just because Andy lives
in New York and it's probably easier for
them to get everyone together I think
they're waiting till the last possible
second so they have all of the in real
time t because so much is happening yeah
yeah I'm I'm dying to know my sources
say and I have some pretty good sources
I'm not gonna lie they say that Lisa
Vanderpump is not filming the reunion
I think she's gonna film well because if
she doesn't film the reunion as we
learned from Adrienne Maloof it has
grounds for firing so that would impact
all the other work she does with Bravo
like you can't just be an enemy of Bravo
but then also be a producer on
Vanderpump rules
I don't think we make her an enemy I
think her not showing up to the ring and
and maybe she doesn't wanna be on
Beverly Hills anymore she's like she
tried to back out before they gave her a
million dollars filming and promised to
talk about you and more yeah I don't I
think she could not go to the reunion
not be a housewife and not be an enemy
of Bravo she's given someone it's but
that's not fair then that's what Lisa
that's what Lisa Rinna was saying on the
Jenny McCarthy show I was like if any of
the ladies pull some of the [ __ ]
that Lisa Vanderpump blows not showing
up for cast pictures having to have a
separate photo shoot refusing to film
with anyone literally not showing up to
a place that you know another housewife
is gonna be at that's grounds for firing
so this advant arm I'm getting special
treatment is not fair especially when
the success of Beverly Hills and Lisa
Rinna all these years being crazy only
contributes to the rising stock of
Beverly Hills the rising stock of Lisa
Vanderpump and
for the rising stock of all of other
lisa vanderpump projects that nobody
makes money off of besides the Savannah
pop lisa rinna has helped in some way or
another
then her pump roles and she has not seen
a dollar from it and that's why she's
mad and that's why she stopped stop
drinking and stop being crazy and only
drinking Aperol spritz is in Berlin yeah
also that I saw some tweets that like
people are wanting brandy to come back
and like it might be time it certainly
even she comes back this season even
Rinna said that she's she kept like
everyone said that they're down for a
brandy come back and imagine if at the
end of the day like Lisa's off the show
and the bread is on I mean Brandi needs
it like big-time and Brandi's great
Ellen easy great housewife yeah she
she's a little I think like she's we
loved her she was crazy like and just in
recent years just from what I've seen I
think she's like a little off the deep
end she would need to like swim back to
shore a little bit I'm sure because she
for so long without her because she was
yes crazy but she was also such a good
friend and a good mom and and like a
good person like with a good heart like
she definitely like had a temper and
alcohol never help but like we always
knew where she was coming from you know
I don't know I've been saying it and I
will still say it I think we're ready
and you know it's Lisa Vanderpump does
say we're even more ready well do you
remember when Kyle Richards almost went
to the dark side against Lisa Vanderpump
in her and Brandi were really good
friends and they went hiking like that
was the best no I know
I still look forward to that I actually
would prefer if Brandi comes on while
Lisa is still there well duh but I mean
I'm there's no way Lisa can be back next
season yeah I think she'll be at the
reunion
they spent I don't know what I think I'm
just saying what my sources say I mean
what do you think given your sources
give it what my sources I don't think
she's gonna show up because what we know
about Lisa Vanderpump is she is not one
to take accountability and reunions are
made for being accountable like you
cannot deny or you can't hide at a
reunion and that's the one thing that
least Adana from fears the most she gets
up from every conversation in the in the
10 years she's been on the show she has
gotten up from every single conversation
where she has been confronted about her
sneakiness and you cannot get up from
reunion it's a whole day okay I have $50
on that she'll be there but I don't
believe that wholeheartedly it's so like
I'll do $20 okay $20 that she won't be
there for you
yeah $20 for me that you're not being
there is way crazier than her being
there of course so if the odds are
stacked against me
I don't even know actually but her being
there eight hours of being held
accountable it also a crazier so no I
know I think she'll be there interesting
thought anyways that's our show for
y'all our last show of the week is
tomorrow before we head to cam toes we
have a special guest tomorrow right or
is that next week
oh yes meet Layla or from Project Runway
oh my god I was a toaster a toaster and
a Project Runway contestant which is
just our favorite mix yeah I'm excited
for that I forgot about that um yeah so
that's our last week of the blush
episode of the week tomorrow and that's
it if you're coming to camp dose we're
excited to see you if you're not be sure
to follow along on the morning shows
Instagram on our instagrams for premium
content being delivered all weekend and
we're really excited about it I'm so
excited um thanks guys have a great day
bye one
tickets available girl [ __ ] calm
Jackie O Flo calm
you